vamos a resolver este problema dice mira
la tabla de esta información hay una
relación funcional entre cada persona y
su altura vamos a pensar qué es esto de
una relación funcional en efecto la
tablet está relacionando nombres con
alturas a wendy le está relacionando con
la altura 1.63 a gabi con 1.61 a arturo
con 1.70 y así sucesivamente pero que
necesitamos para que sea una relación
funcional pues por ejemplo si queremos
que la altura quede en función del
nombre necesitamos que para cada nombre
haya únicamente una altura entonces
déjame ponerle aquí
altura altura que es lo que vamos a
pensar como la función y vamos a pensar
que la variable independiente es el
nombre entonces esta que es la función
altura recibe aquí nombres entonces para
que sea una función aquí al poner un
nombre debemos de obtener un único valor
es decir debemos de tener una única
altura relacionada a cada uno de los
nombres y hay dos o más entonces esto no
puede ser función y si en efecto
funciona por ejemplo si aquí
y le pongo juan insípido la altura de
juan
entonces puedo irme a la tabla ver con
que está relacionado juan nada más hay
un juan está relacionado con la altura
1.74 y por lo tanto aquí sería igual a
un 1.74 vale 1.74 y lo mismo pasa con el
resto de los nombres si pongo gabi me da
1.61 si pongo leo me da 1.70 entonces
tenemos 1 y sólo un valor incluso
podríamos hacer una gráfica dejando
poner por aquí los ejes este de aquí va
a ser el eje de altura altura este de
acá va a ser el eje de nombres le voy a
poner aquí nombres
hombres muy bien aquí en el eje de
altura voy a poner escala pues vamos a
pensar que por acá y más o menos por acá
está está un metro por acá está
cincuenta centímetros unos cincuenta más
o menos puede que no me quede muy muy
exacta la escala 170 por aquí arriba
está unos 74 entonces está de aquí va a
ser mi escala este es 1.5 1.6 1.7 más o
menos y en los nombres
voy a poner nada más las iniciales para
que no sea tan complicado entonces voy a
poner aquí una w de wendy le voy a poner
con colores voy a poner una g de gavin
de gabi voy a poner una a de arturo
y yo estar la a una jota de juan jota de
juan y finalmente voy a poner una ele de
leo entonces aquí va a estar el de leo
entonces si tomamos a wendy podemos
graficar su altura correspondiente
marcando el puntito a la altura que debe
ir o sea a 1.63 déjame poner el punto
por ahí estaría más o menos por aquí
1.63 algo de ese estilo vale ahora
podemos pasarnos a gabi en color rosa
tendríamos que irnos a 1.61 es un
poquito abajo de wendy más o menos algo
como de este estilo vale si nos pasamos
a arturo con arturo tenemos que poner
1.70 él es un poco más alto como por acá
luego tenemos que ir a juan que es el
más alto de todos es 1.74 1.74 como por
ahí y finalmente a leo leo que mide 170
observa que mide lo mismo que arturo
pero esto no es ningún problema porque a
leo le estamos asignando un valor que es
1.70
1.70 vale entonces aquí se nota que para
cualquier nombre que tengamos tenemos
una única altura y por lo tanto no hay
ningún problema y en efecto esto de aquí
es una relación funcional pero entonces
debes de preguntarte hay a poco todo es
función pues no resulta que no todo es
función aquí podríamos tener problemas
si repitiéramos algún nombre por ejemplo
si aquí pondría que y aquí sí aquí
pusiera que arturo que arturo me dé y de
180 voy a ponerle 180 entonces ya
tendríamos problemas porque a la hora de
intentar determinar la altura altura de
arturo le voy a poner de arturo con este
color azul
arturo entonces no podríamos decir pues
cuál es el valor correspondiente porque
no sabemos si tenemos que irnos a que la
altura de arturo es 180 o es 170 aquí no
sabríamos qué sucede pero bueno en el
problema original no tenemos esto de acá
déjame borrar a esta altura de 180 no
tenemos esto de acá entonces aquí
sabemos exactamente que la altura de
arturo es igual a 1.70 sin ningún
problema porque hay un único valor para
cada nombre excelente entonces bueno en
realidad este es un concepto muy simple
pero algunas veces es posible
confundirse un poco lo que es más
importante de todo es acordarse de esta
idea de que para que algo sea una
relación funcional para cada valor en el
dominio debemos tener un 1
o valor en el contra dominio vale bueno
espero que te haya sido de ayuda nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo